hey youtubers is Charlie and this week
on Game of Thrones
it was totally time to throw down the
episode was directed by Neil Marshall he
directed Blackwater from season two so
if the episode felt like a sequel to
that
that's why real quick before round 9 of
the giveaway starts now just as a way to
say thank you to all you guys for being
so awesome I'm picking a random
subscriber from the comments on this
video to give an Amazon gift card to
I'll announce who the winner is whenever
I post my Q&A video tomorrow night so
much to talk about so let's just get
right in it so what I'm gonna do is
start with my top 5 WTF moments then I'm
gonna do my review and then I'll circle
back around for any plot threads that we
need to remember before the finale so
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet but number 5 master Amon
explains love even for a Targaryen
master Amon was on fire tonight in fact
he was my favorite supporting character
Alliser thorne got a pretty good battle
speech but I feel like Amon speech about
love was way better if you're not
familiar
Amon is the great uncle of the Mad King
when his older brothers died they
offered him the crown but he turned it
down and took the black that's what he
was talking about when he said he was at
court and women were throwing themselves
at him I couldn't find out who the woman
he was talking about the woman that he
was in love with or which house she
belonged to so if you do know just write
it in the comments below I like how he
foreshadowed Ygritte and Jon Snow's
reunion with his big takeaway quote love
is the death of duty their duty was to
chop each other's heads off but because
they were still in love they just forgot
about it whenever the time came I also
think it's really cool when you start to
think about unending love and the threat
of White Walkers and necromancy like if
Jon Snow had not told Sam wealth to burn
the bodies at the end his and egrets
love might turn into zombie white love
and literally become undying I did not
see master Amon during the battle so
fingers crossed that he survived to the
finale
number 4 Jon Snow explains what it means
to be in love I don't believe for a
minute that he's not a bloody poet the
whole gossipy exchange that would have
been really funny in any other episode
but because this episode was like 2
towers in the Battle of Helm's Deep
it was very wishful Samwell did get a
few moments with Gilly and they have
their own kind of love but really it did
seem like he just wanted to know what it
was like to have sex
I loved how hard his brain was working
to try and find a way past there oh so
you could just hook up with Gilly not
feel guilty about it
to be fair Nights Watch Brothers have
broken the
I know sex oath all the time over the
years I say implied because Samwell was
correct with his literal interpretation
of the oath really he should just go for
it but if anything happens between them
I had the feeling that Gilly is going to
be the one to make the first move number
three the wildlings attack on two fronts
Jon was correct when he was saying mance
was just testing their northern defenses
they have a whole lot more Giants where
those two came from the Giants lifting
the gate actually reminded me of Return
of the Jedi whenever the rancor died
they killed that one giant and the other
one flipped out that was not the only
Return of the Jedi reference I saw
either the episode felt like a mix of
two towers Star Wars and Star Trek it
was amazing the way they altered the
theme song for the battle made it so
much cooler if he didn't notice it was
just a little off tempo version of the
opening credits theme song it started
whenever Jon jumped down off the lift
and started swinging Longclaw around it
really did seem like the music in the
episode was all drums and string bass
that early shot when the raiding party
was rushing the south gate gave us that
amazing panoramic shot that went from
them panned up the wall and out over
Mance's army just a hammer home that
mance was attacking from the north and
the Raiders from the south at the same
time I'm really hoping in that finale
they give us a daylight shot of Mance's
army just like a real big wide shot to
give you an idea of the scale the Nights
Watch only had about a hundred men
before tonight's battle so they're
probably down to like 50 or 60 that big
north gate is still intact but if it
only took one giant to lift it it's not
going to be much comfort number two Jon
Snow takes command this was like his
Kobayashi Maru the unwinnable scenario
that's why I mentioned Star Trek earlier
I'll go as far to say that that scenario
is still not over at the end of this
episode
he still has to deal with that giant
army he's still in the middle of this
unwinnable scenario I love Todd Dolores
ed invented a reason for yeah no slip to
go back down I kind of half expected
them to just punch him and make him pass
out it's like the show is preparing us
for Jon to take a leadership role Janos
Slynt is the only other senior commander
that's left alive right now so it's
unclear whether or not they're going to
actually pass command like real command
of the Nights Watch to Jon this season
or they're going to turn it into some
big plot that will carry over to season
5 one of my favorite moments though it
was when the brothers on top of the wall
asked Jon how he knew the climbers
wouldn't get to the top till morning
because I totally made that climb and my
number one WTF moment of course Ygritte
dies
that way John smiled at her at the end
was just so amazing that was my favorite
reaction shot from the episode I'm not
sure if he was thinking about the strong
arrow she had trained on him but this is
where master a man's quote came full
circle they both just kind of freeze I
totally did not see that little kid
coming I thought they were gonna let him
kill the big fent in some sort of
revenge moment for them killing his
family
that's why Game of Thrones is so awesome
though now John feels extra guilty about
egrets death which probably led to
John's decision to enter the Dragons maw
of manses camp without a weapon without
long cloth it's so sad to see Ygritte go
but did anyone think that they were not
a tragic couple it's like relationships
especially weddings equal death on the
show so maybe Sam is better off not
knowing what sex is like I definitely
think the rest of John's heart died
tonight like he is frozen solid to the
core now it'll probably be his sense of
duty that'll keep him going however he
will probably never laugh out loud again
or smile but now it's your turn let me
know in the comments below what was your
biggest WTF moment I have a feeling
we're all on the same page in thinking
the same unfortunate ginger thoughts but
her last line you know nothing Jon Snow
is right off the page of the book if you
want to read her death scene it's
actually book 3 John chapter 7 overall I
felt like the whole episode from a
production standpoint with just an
a-plus it was amazing it really was like
a direct sequel to the Blackwater
episode at least in terms of scope the
battle also reminded me a lot of the
battle for Helm's Deep in two towers
from the way they altered the music to
the wildlings charging very cinematic
very awesome do not be surprised if this
episode gets nominated for a technical
Emmy those are just the Emmys they give
for production like I said Neil Marshall
directed this episode he's the guy that
directed the Blackwater episode which
was also kind of like a helms deep
episode - hums deep with a lot of
wildfire just comparing the two episodes
I think from a production standpoint and
an emotional payoff Blackwater is still
my favorite kit harington is awesome but
almost no one else on the show can hold
a candle to Peter Dinklage I guess
during Blackwater Joffrey would have
been their version of Janos Slynt like
the person in charge who's just a huge
coward just because I think the
Blackwater was a little bit better
doesn't mean I didn't like this episode
I didn't think it was really amazing but
it feels like they were really just
holding half the story back for the
Nally even if it only was half a story
it was still a freaking awesome half of
a story
whenever John passed through the gate to
go meet with mance did anyone else get a
flash of Return of the Jedi from Luke
standing outside Jabba's palace with the
big gate there even John left his sword
behind just like Luke didn't have his
lightsaber so I wonder if they did it on
purpose like that the thing I'm really
most curious about right now is what
they're gonna end the season on which
moment there's a lot of big plots still
floating around in the air
I'll leave a lot of that discussion for
my Q&A video tomorrow but here are a few
things left hanging in the episode first
off what the hell is John gonna do when
he gets to manses camp I don't think
that anyone else believes that he's
going to be able to kill him Janos Slynt
is also still an issue they mostly used
him for comedy in this episode but he
has been a pain in John's ass all season
and what the hell are they gonna do with
tormund Giantsbane he's one of the
wildlings best fighters there's no way
he's giving up information unless the
Nights Watch wants to learn about sex
with bears seriously that was one of the
funniest parts of the episode so feel
free to ask any remaining plot questions
for the finale or anything else please
use spoiler tags if you've read the
books and you want to talk about books 4
& 5 stuff also because next week is the
finale I'm going to be doing extra
special bonus videos all the way through
this week and next week my next one is
probably gonna be ranking the previous
finales but feel free to leave me
suggestions so right now you can click
here to get that Q&A video ah the
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here to learn about all the
most important prophecies on the show
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives
[Music]
you